Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Hong Kong–Chinese culinary drama film
called “Cook Up a Storm.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie centers around a famous local
restaurant named the Seven, in Spring Avenue
Hong Kong. The talented chef of the restaurant,
Sky Ko, specializes in southern-style cuisine.
A TV host features the thirty-year-old restaurant
and its chef on a culinary program. Sky shows his
talent on national television, even though he is
already popular as the best chef in all of Spring
Avenue. Alongside him, his friend Uni is also
introduced to the people. She usually manages
the financial aspect of the restaurant. Sky is
very definitive about the quality of food and
time they provide to their customers which is part
of the reason why their restaurant is so popular.
Most of the time, it is so packed that a queue of
people has to line up outside the restaurant.
That day, a rude customer barges in after breaking
the queue. Sky refuses to serve him even though
the customer boasts about the power and money
he possesses. Before leaving, the man laughs at
their small restaurant and discloses that his
boss has invited a world-class chef to open a
three-star restaurant opposite theirs. The thought
scares Uni but she dismisses it as a bluff.
Meanwhile, in France, the crowned king and queen
are welcoming their newborn son. They hold a
massive ball to celebrate the birth and invite a
world-class chef to cook for the guests. We are
introduced to the said chef, Paul Ahn. He is a
Michelin-starred Korean chef trained in France.
Paul has a special way of cooking that doesn’t
see boundaries in one particular style. He loves
to mix cuisines from different countries and hence
create innovative dishes. For the chef’s special,
he presents the queen with a dessert that looks
like a red egg but is filled with mango puree
and coconuts. The dish is inspired by the
tradition that symbolizes red eggs as a
blessing to the newborn. The delicious dish
and the meaning behind it touch the royals’
hearts and they applaud Paul’s brilliant work.
After the successful ball, he and his assistant
Mayo return to the restaurant that they currently
work in. The owner and their co-workers welcome
them with cheers, congratulating them on their
success. The owner also announces that they have
promoted Paul to the executive chef of the whole
Art Nouveau franchise. The step is a huge one for
him; however, to everyone’s surprise, he declines
the offer. Paul wants to return to Asia and pursue
a bigger and higher ambition. He and Mayo have
been invited by a Chinese businessman who wants to
open a three-star restaurant. The staff supports
their decision and wishes them farewell.
Back in Spring Avenue, one of Sky’s regular
customers informs him that the rumor about a
new restaurant being established is true. The
news is bittersweet for Sky because he wants
his small colony to develop, but a new restaurant
would mean fewer customers and more competition.
When Sky was ten years old, his father used to hit
him and insult him for having no talent as a cook.
One day, he abandoned Sky and chose to pursue
his culinary career over being a father
with the excuse that Sky couldn’t even make a
decent bowl of noodles. Ever since, Uncle Seven,
the master and owner of the Seven
restaurants, has taken care of him.
He also taught Sky everything that he needed to
know about food, unlike his father. Currently,
Sky hasn't met his father in over twenty years
and has no plan to reconcile with him.
The following morning, Paul arrives in Hong
Kong and goes to the market in search of a
big grouper fish. The seller only has one
of such and decides to sell it to Sky,
knowing that he will cook it better. Paul argues,
insisting that a shopkeeper shouldn’t be biased.
They get into a small argument before
the seller cuts the fish in half
for both of them. A few weeks later is the
opening ceremony of the three-star restaurant
named Stellar that is right in front of the Seven
restaurant. The chairman and manager of the Li
Management Group arrive as the first guests of the
restaurant and are welcomed by Paul and Mayo.
At the same time, the people from the Seven
restaurant start announcing about different
discount offers they are offering for the next
week. When the security guards from the Stellar
restaurant try to stop them, a conflict arises.
This attracts Paul and the guests’ attention,
making them come out to see what the fuss
is about. When the conversation gets heated,
Mayo suggests they hold a competition to see which
cook is better. Sky and Paul recognize each other
from the market and accept the challenge. They
decide to indulge in a fish cutting competition.
Paul goes first and skilfully picks all the
ribs of a fish in no time Following that,
Sky takes the same fish and cuts it into even
pieces in under a minute. The crowd claps for
him and even Paul is impressed. The chairman of
the Li group has to announce the results.
In an unbiased way, he claims that the
true results will only be announced in the
International Chef Challenge Competition that both
chefs have taken part in. He also announces that
he is planning to take over the entire Spring
Avenue colony to remove all the buildings and
modernize it. If Sky wins in the competition,
the chairman is willing to withdraw his plan
to preserve the heritage of the colony. However,
if Paul wins, he will go through with the plan.
With the future of the entire colony in his hands,
Sky feels pressured, still, he is determined to
do his best. For the next few days, the number
of customers at the Seven restaurant decreases.
Uni is worried that might soon go out of business
but Sky assures her that is not possible. He gives
her an example of escargots and field snails,
claiming that there will always be people who
like one more than the other. They do not
have to change their food to be better than
the Stellar restaurant, because there will
always be customers who like one better.
The following day, Sky is met with disappointment
when he goes to the market and finds out the
Stellar restaurant has bought all the good
fish. The day is frustrating for the workers
in the Seven restaurant until they find out
that Sky has been selected for the culinary
competition. He will soon go against Paul to
be selected for the semi-finals. But then,
it is also announced that the victor will have to
go against the two-time winner of the competition,
Mountain Ko. Sky is shocked to see that his
father has achieved the success he wanted to.
He is now even more determined to reach
the finals and compete against him.
That night, uncle Seven returns home from his
trip and calls Sky to a pub. Excited to meet
him after long, Sky runs to the location
but finds his father with uncle Seven.
Mountain bluntly says that he still doesn’t
believe in Sky and doesn’t regret leaving him
for his career. The words are the most hurtful
thing Sky has ever heard but he hides his pain
with anger. He promises to win the competition
and prove that being a good cook doesn’t
require being a bad person like Mountain is.
On the day of the culinary duel, the contestants
get ninety minutes to cook a dish of their
choice and present it. Sky makes a traditional
salt-baked duck while Paul makes a foie gras
sorbet. The entire ninety minutes are intense
as both cooks show great expertise while cooking
their respective dishes. Sky cuts the duck’s
inside with little to no effort and pulls it
out efficiently, making the audience gasp.
In the end, he bakes the duck in salt and breaks
the additional layer to reveal a well-cooked duck
with vegetable stuffings. The judges try it
and seem to be more impressed by Sky’s duck
than Paul’s sorbet. When it is time to vote, Paul
receives three 9s and a whopping 10 out of 10,
scoring a total of thirty-seven points. Right
after, Sky receives two 10s from the first two
judges. The third one gives him nine but
the last judge only gives him an eight.
Because both chefs tied in points, the head
judge makes the executive decision to make
Paul the winner because his dish presentation
was superior to Sky's bland plating.
Although Paul’s victory should've
solidified his abilities as a cook,
things do not go as expected. While celebrating
their victory, the manager informs Paul that he
wants to replace him with Mayo to compete in the
finals. According to him, a woman is far more
appealing in the media than a man. When Paul
tries to defend his position as head chef, Mayo
exposes that he has difficulty tasting certain
flavors like saltiness. For the past few months,
he has been using a notebook containing all his
recipes to cook and can do nothing on his own.
Mayo also discloses that she never wanted to
befriend Paul and only sided with him to surpass
him as a chef. Betrayed and hurt, Paul storms
out of the restaurant to never look back.
That night, Sky bumps into a drunk Paul in
front of an event stadium. They forget about
their rivalry for a few minutes and share their
past and troubles. Paul reveals that his father
was a great chef and his dying wish was for Paul
to be like him. Sky also tells him about his and
mountain’s relationship. After the conversation,
they find mutual respect for each other. They also
throw bottles of alcohol at Mountain’s picture on
a billboard while cursing at him in Korean.
Paul doesn’t want to give up on the competition
yet. Since he cannot take part as a representative
of the Stellar restaurant, he decides to
participate as an individual chef after
debunking the rule book. He even asks Sky to
join him for the semi-finals. At the same time,
the manager of Stellar is at the Seven restaurant
urging Uncle Seven to sign away his restaurant to
the Li group. Right then, Paul and Sky appear and
announce their partnership. Paul also reminds the
manager that as the winner of the competition, he
is eligible to compete at the championship.
For the next few weeks, Sky and Paul work
and train together. They try each other’s
style of cooking and reach a common ground
of modernization of traditional cuisine.
The semi-final of the Culinary Competition
takes place at the Studio City Casino in
Macau. The one to win the round will have to
face the current God of Cookery, Mountain Ko.
The competition starts and Sky and Paul use both
their culinary strengths to compete against four
other great chefs from different parts of the
world. Somehow, the Li group has also made Mayo
take part in the competition. She cooks extra
carefully to prove that she is better than Paul.
She makes an oyster dish with frozen foam that
the judges compliment initially, but on being
served, they seem to find it mediocre.
Meanwhile, Paul and Sky create a deconstructed
mapo tofu. Sky's sense of taste helps determine
the flavor of the ingredients while Paul’s
understanding of the culinary artistry helps
with the techniques and processes used. Together,
they create a traditional dish with a modern
design. The judges complement the dish in detail,
thoroughly impressed by it. In the end, they
win the competition and reach the finale.
As everyone cheers, Paul looks at Mayo who
stands with her head low, ashamed that she
betrayed him and couldn’t prove herself.
For the final round, only one of the chefs
can compete against Mountain. Paul thinks that
because of his lack of taste, he is ineligible
to participate. He also knows that Sky's desire
to beat Mountain is a very personal one, hence he
suggests Sky face Mountain in the finals.
The following day, Sky stands face to face
with his father. The competition asks
them to cook anything they want in an
hour. The father and son do not share
words before the competition starts.
Mountain immediately begins to cook
but Sky is distracted by his thoughts.
He remembers how Mountain abandoned him and how
much the people in the neighborhood mean to him.
The thoughts overwhelm Sky and he can hardly
focus. To get him to come back to his senses,
Mountain splashes water at his son's face.
The action brings Sky back and he immediately
starts making dough. By the end of the hour,
Mountain makes an aesthetic sugar display of
molten lava with a flower on top. In contrast,
Sky's dish is a bit more simple but personal. He
makes noodles, like the noodles that Mountain
made years ago before abandoning his son. The
judges try Mountain’s dish and are impressed by
it. However, Sky never hands his dish to them.
Instead, he gives the bowl of noodles to
Mountain. Mountain eats it and is moved
as he remembers what the noodles represent.
At last, he has no choice but to acknowledge
his son’s brilliance in culinary art. The
winner of the competition is unclear because
the judges never got to taste the food.
In the following scene, we see a crowd has
gathered outside the Seven restaurant to celebrate
the Chinese new year. They enjoy a meal cooked by
Sky and Paul together as a family.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.